okay so the next non-existent Batman
movie which we'll call Batman three has
had the most outlandish rumors rumors
ranging from Megan Fox being Catwoman to
Pluto Nash being the Riddler but
hopefully in January that [ __ ] will
change so some of you may have heard
Christopher Nolan the director of The
Dark Knight and Warner Brothers have an
announcement in January yes this is a
video showing my epic nerdiness this
announcement has to be Batman related it
has been a year and a half since the
Dark Knight came out people are out here
making rumors and making up fake teasers
for the next Batman movie that is like a
fat guy drawing a picture of a Twinkie
after a month-long fast what to do just
feed him and by him I mean us now
another Batman movie is gonna happen no
matter what you do not make over a
billion dollars in Chapter two of a
franchise and then call it quits it is
Warner Brothers they've proven to us
before that no matter what they will
always make another Batman movie even if
it is god-awful and it features Arnold
so no matter who directs it Batman 3 is
inevitable on the other hand this
announcement could be some pointless
announcement on Christopher Nolan's new
movie Inception I hope for their sake
that's not the case because when it's
announced that the Dark Knight's studio
and the Dark Knight director have an
announcement to make no one thinks
inception I would say it would be
borderline cruel for them to be like
hello well thank you all for coming out
I am mr. Warner that does my brother
know so we the Warner Brothers and mr.
Nolan would like to put these rumors to
rest once and for all so we are here to
publicly say once and for all that no
inception was not influenced by The
Matrix thank you
safe to say unless they want the LA
riots 2010 edition they will make their
announcement Batman related so the
question becomes why hasn't Christopher
Nolan jumped on the next Batman movie I
think most people out there agree he
probably intended to have the Joker
somewhere in the third Batman movie and
Ledger died in January if this
announcement is that Christopher Nolan's
gonna do the next Batman should he
recast the Joker and I understand both
sides of it really I used to be all like
no it's Ledger's role you can't recast
it it wouldn't be the same I hate recast
unless it's Rachel das Rachel Dawes
Batman Begins way hotter Rachel does
Dark Knight looked like she actually
didn't have to sleep with the DA to get
her job but as for the Joker if Nolan
ended the Dark Knight intending to bring
the Joker somewhere into the third movie
then the third Batman is going to go
one of two ways recast the Joker or
compromised the story by going in a
different direction than you originally
intended when you made the Dark Knight
just don't compromise the story because
there is strong speculation that the
next main villains gonna be the Riddler
makes sense and it would be cool to have
the Joker in that situation because in
certain Batman lore the Joker and the
Riddler stories intertwine all
interesting like yeah I did warn you
epic nerdiness but no matter what
happens we can all agree that the next
Batman movie will only be worth watching
if Christopher Nolan directs it which is
why next months should be awesome unless
it's one of those mommy and daddy have
something to tell you guys we're getting
a divorce
a creative divorce yeah that would blow
because who are we kidding if
Christopher Nolan doesn't direct it's
gonna go to Brett Ratner or some [ __ ]
and then they can finally prove to us
that he can rape any franchise but the
slightest of effort and the utmost of
ease because we all know how much we
liked x-men 3 so since it's a safe bet
to assume that there's not a human being
out there who thinks that Christopher
Nolan shouldn't direct the next Batman
movie the question becomes what do you
think he should do recast the Joker or
go in a different direction or wait to
see if James Cameron loans his Nobby CGI
to Christopher Nolan to recreate the
Joker all digital like just joking kind
of but not really yes I do read your
comments and your mail I try to get back
to all you guys but it doesn't always
happen but I do appreciate the comments
and before you leave don't forget to
subscribe by clicking the link in the
sidebar and hitting